Apple said that 8 GB in a Mac is
equivalent to 16 gig in a Windows
computer but honestly that seems a bit
too farfetched so today we are going to
test that I have an M3 Mac with 8 gigs
compared to a Windows machine that has
16 GB and we're going to see not the
overall performance but does the Mac
still keep up once you are multitasking
doing different things like people do
compared to a Windows computer in which
one will slow down more the first thing
I'm going to do is restart both of these
computers that way we start a fresh and
I have to say that I agree with our
commenters that we should at least have
12 gigs in a system that cost
$1,600 and now I have the activity
monitors opened up we have 5.8 gigs out
of 8 's just with Mac OS compared to 5.7
out of our 16 now I'm going to start out
with a few Baseline tests as far as
performance with nothing else open and
as you guys could see the MacBook is
quicker at web applications and tasks
compared to the Windows computer but
that could flip once we have things open
and now I have Adobe Lightroom classic
opened with 50 of these edited
highresolution images and now let's go
ahead and Export these to get our
Baseline the MacBook took a minute and
47 seconds compared to a minute and 17
so the Windows computer is faster and
it's using 10 GB of Ram compared to the
Mac which already is having to use 2
and2 gab of SSD as RAM because it
doesn't have enough even with nothing
else open and now I have D Vinci resolve
18 Studio opened up and both these are
having no issues playing through this
Blackmagic raw project and rendering
these they're running very close in
terms of speed we have 3 minutes and 22
seconds compared to 3 minutes and 12 and
now I have Photoshop open we are going
to be doing a photo merge and that took
a minute and 48 compared to a minute and
44 so very close in terms of performance
and now I shut everything down and I
opened up Chrome with 10 web browsing
tabs I usually Ed around 30 so we're
keeping it simple I have Google Drive
open uh spreadsheet a document a couple
email pages and then a few websites um
going up to YouTube which I'm typically
playing some music in the background or
a video like this MKBHD video and with
only these web browsing tabs we are
using about 400 Megs of the SSD as RAM
on the Mac compared to the windows which
is actually using less Ram overall and
of course we're going to test the
performance now with this real world use
but I want to mention that a lot of
Windows laptops will allow you to
upgrade your RAM like this Lenovo
there's an empty slot so I can very
cheaply for about 50 to 70 bucks make
this a 32 gig where with a Mac one it
costs way more than that and you cannot
do it after you buy it which makes it
more important to have enough RAM and
now let's go ahead and minimize our
Chrome browser and now let's export
these again and we'll see if we have any
differences holy moly guys we are using
6.3 gigs of swap on the Mac while the
Windows computer is taking 12 gigs out
of its 16 and the Windows computer is
actually faster this time a minute and
so those 10 web browsing tabs didn't
really phase it compared to the Mac
which took 2 minutes and 10 seconds
instead of a minute and 47 previously
and that right there is starting to
prove that no 8 gigs is not the same as
16 now unified memory is more efficient
I will absolutely agree but 8 gigs is
just not enough in a system that costs
this amount of money and that's labeled
a pro machine and now I have Da Vinci
resolve opened up right here I'm doing
the same exact export and I can right
away see that the Mac is going slower
than it was before okay guys this is
insane the Mac was slower instead of
taking 3 minutes 22 seconds it took 339
not a massive difference but it is
slowing down whereas the Windows laptop
went from 312 to 258 it actually likes
having more things open in the
background and now let's test Photoshop
again this time the Mac was only
slightly slower than before while the PC
was exactly the same and now let's test
some multitasking let's go ahead and
open up Chrome that was fairly smooth
let's go Ahad and go to YouTube and
they're actually doing a fairly similar
job now for True multitasking I have to
do this next step I'm going to go ahead
and open up Lightroom again because I
typically have either Photoshop and
video editing open or if I'm doing
Lightroom I all Photoshop open and I'm
going to my browser let's hit export
here and then I'm going to go ahead and
go into Photoshop a little bit faster on
the Windows there let's open up this HDR
setup it's starting to load the images
and align the layers here while it's
doing that let's shck on Lightroom looks
like the PC is almost done there bam it
did take about 5 Seconds longer than
last time so it did slow down but the ma
is just at a stand still here let's go
on to photoshop this has been loaded up
for I don't know how long here we are
still spinning and typically a Mac will
be quicker at loading up images this
thing is just crawling right now and
clicking on Lightroom barely moved here
now I've done a lot of these kind of
testings in the past and we compare this
8 gig to a 16 and it was a dramatic
difference when you're multitasking so I
didn't touch the system there until
light finish and that took 4 minutes and
1 second compared to the original a
minute and 47 seconds and now let's try
something different keep in mind guys we
only have 50 images here I never do just
50 and we also only have 10 web browsing
tabs which I never only have 10
personally let's go ahead and open up
Chrome and let's go ahead and switch
both of them had to take longer to load
there and in Photoshop our system is
starting to slow down just look between
just the these two images there's
definitely a delay and now opening up
our web browser
again bam we're slowing down look at
that dang so you guys could see that no
8 GB is not the same at 16 uh especially
when you're going to be actually be
using the system in my previous videos I
pushed it harder I had 20 tabs open
multiple different things and and I have
to say I agree with you guys when you
said that Apple should at least put 12
gigs into a $1600 system the M3 Pro
would still have 18 it would still be a
reason to kind of Step Up and upgrade
but that would give it a little bit more
oomph because even with nothing open we
had 5 and2 gigs used out of eight that's
2 and2 gigs remaining for applications
and the crazy thing is the same system
with 16 gigs of RAM is way faster even
with nothing open at at all so please
Apple stop giving us 8 gigs when it's
pretty much
2024 you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next
[Music]
one